would you guys consider yourself um
would you consider yourself a feminist
i just don't like putting myself in a
label
i agree a lot with the feminist movement
but
yeah i don't like labels and i feel like
feminism has kind of slightly been
hijacked by radical feminists and i
think any extreme of any i don't know
organization or
movement is bad i think extremes are bad
and i feel like
yeah i just feel like i have my beliefs
i don't need to attach a label to them
personally so yeah okay what about you
guys
i agree with you yeah yeah
i don't think there's any
thing to really add on like before she
said to be fine okay
so do you guys think that radical
feminists have taken over feminism
high key yeah
at least in society's view of what
feminism is
i think a lot of people don't understand
where why feminism started in the first
place and then what the core values of
are of feminism
um
yeah that's kind of so why why would you
say it started in the first place and
what are the core values from my
understanding of feminism
um i understand that it started from
women wanting the right to vote that's
okay okay i know of it okay
and what about the core values
um
equality for men and women at least in
terms of
kind of right to vote i don't know if it
started i don't know if women could work
back then um
potentially um
violence against women as well because i
know
up until what the 90s it was legal for a
man to
uh
grape a woman okay in their relationship
and thank you
thank you
nothing could happen to him um so just
stuff like that because i personally
believe that
men and women are different and i do
believe we should be treated equally but
we're not equal and i do understand that
in certain contexts we can't do we can't
be treated the same or certain things
aren't going to work the same for each
person but i believe in stuff in terms
of like pay
and um
sexual violence i don't know if i'd say
that um and stuff like that yeah we
should be treated with the same and i
feel like there are a lot of double
standard society now so yeah do you what
do you guys feel like in 2022 we're
fighting for in terms of equality
because i know historically like we
wanted the right to vote which funny
thing is um the majority of women didn't
actually want the right to vote because
it meant you were enlisted in the draft
oh i didn't know that yeah no i didn't
know that for a while either i'm sad
and i mean if i had to be drafted or
give up my right to vote i would give it
up same
i don't even care about politics by
in 2022 what do you think we need
feminism for
are there any rights you feel like we
don't have
radio silence
i guess no
no obviously we can't think of anything
yeah so what is the the purpose of
feminism then if if there's nothing more
to uh achieve in terms of women's rights
well that's the thing i feel like it's
sorry i just feel like it's evolved now
into
i just yeah i think it's just been
hijacked a bit yeah i think like
this have been lost a bit like when
pearl was asking you guys uh do you
consider yourselves feminist like i
would genuinely consider myself a
feminist but in the context of gender
equality of outcome
right
of sorry not outcome excuse me of
opportunity i should correct that
uh equality of opportunity means that
you know if a woman does want to be a
bricklayer she can go be a bricklayer
she does want to be a soldier she can go
be a soldier if a man wants to be a
nurse go be a nurse etc
but
when it comes to
like
i think where the issue is now with
feminism is that it's become
a scapegoat for just mishandry
meaning like just hatred towards
think and i think we can see this with
the johnny depp and amber heard case
where feminism went too far
because if that happened to a man with
power money and influence how many
average men did that happen to number
one and number two she walked
she did all that i mean she's broke now
but she's not in jail
if a man chopped off a woman's finger
wow yeah where would he he would be in
prison
he would never get out
yeah but can i say like
you know where feminism has gone too far
perhaps yeah in uh it's misandry and so
on i also think that the quote-unquote
red pill
also kind of
has taken some hope from a percentage of
men who now in turn evolve into becoming
you know women haters and thinking oh
there's just nothing but hoes out there
whatever the woman only wants me for my
money or a woman who do you who do you
think is i i think of rolo tomasi as
like the father of the red pill would
you agree with that or disagree um
father of the right
when i think of i i know there's some
people maybe before him that aren't
alive anymore i think um i've heard that
yeah i'm look i'm not some like red pill
scholar you know what i'm saying but um
there's one guy i think alexander grace
who i think is the person that i've
listened to
um
and i found his uh content quite
informational he's regurgitating a lot
of um rolo tomasi's ideas yeah but i
don't see i don't see the red pill as
like making angry man-hating or
women-hating men i see it as exposing
men to the reality that a lot of a lot
of them will not reproduce because they
are not
qualified to sure as sad as that is but
i think a lot of men
take that information and they don't
think oh i need to rise up to the
challenge increase my value and go out
there and do what i need to do but yeah
that's the men's fault that's the men's
fault absolutely but i'm saying like the
red pill oh like every red pill channel
is self-improvement ever
i can't think of one that says get angry
at women
i think it's just i think it's just men
say oh i have to go make out a lot of
money there's certain men that that's i
call them the video game addicted and
like corn addicted
group of
group of men
and they they say oh i have to make a
lot of money to get a woman
i have to be attractive to get a woman i
have to get in shape
and they know that they don't have the
qualities to do it so they get mad
because they probably will die alone
because and that's not a whole it's not
a fun reality absolutely i think for
those people that have gone into that
mental mentality
you've put yourself into that mentality
if you're if you're really unattractive
there are things you can do to go from a
four to a five yeah or from a two to
three you get jacked what percent of men
are in super good shape absolutely it's
not it's not the majority even as a
woman like them i want to say 50 of
women are overweight so if you get in
really good shape you're like in the top
20 of women like statistically men it's
similar
but i think you know maybe i shouldn't
conflate the red pill with
men going their own way and all that
kind of stuff
but i do think that there is a a rise
within the man of sphere
like generally of just hatred towards
women in general i think we need to be
objective about gender dynamics how
you know uh
men and women are different how they're
similar whatever
but
i think we are
you know this this red the red pill
conversation the conversation that's
happening within like feminist circles
and so on i think it's just building a
greater divide
and i think that's where you are so
important pearl because you are inviting
feminists to have an open dialogue and
so on like to bridge that gap see i
don't i think people just like the
divide is people being unhappy with
their their reality which for women is
they can't get the guys they want and
for men is a certain percentage of men
is they can't get anyone but i don't
necessarily think it's the red pill i
think the red pill just
exposes you to reality and i do
understand a little bit but i think
where you're talking about like the
angry
um like the divisive titles and stuff
yes
yeah it's kind of it's sad but it's kind
of the game with youtube that's the
thing the algorithm incentivizes that
stuff
yeah and and so i think sometimes people
lose the message with the title
like i i did a i did a show the other
day which i labeled like ladies let your
man cheat i don't want to be with a
cheater i don't think it's okay to cheat
but the whole conversation was
cheating's different for men and for
women and would you give up
monogamy if it meant you're getting 10k
a month
from from your guy a lot of girls say
you know what i can deal with that if
i'm getting enough money and like that
was the conversation but if someone just
looks at the title they might think that
i i seriously am endorsing cheating
so you're thinking about it right
what
i think about and i'm just 20k 30k
just keep going okay
sorry i feel like that's so debatable
because like obviously you're getting a
20km off
it's good yeah but like i'm going to be
the
so you get you get to um
discuss that it's like oh you can't
speak about it outside no one can know
if people find out then it's just with
high-end it's like escorts high-end
escorts no no so these these girls are
beautiful and their job their job is to
stay clean these are high-end escorts
that's all he's going to use
occasionally here and there no paying me
to do that no no no no he's paying you
he you're his wife you're the girl on
his arm okay and the reason he's picking
escorts is so no one else on the planet
will know
but he he's a guy he likes sexual
variety here and there but these girls
are paid to shut their mouth and stay
clean
and they're nothing it's just a hoe
there's there's there's nothing
long-term the wife knows about it well
the wife knows the what this is a this
is there's a certain percentage of men
that this is normal to this is what they
do
and the vowels don't mean captain it
doesn't it no no she agrees to it
because she's getting thirty thousand
dollars a month to live
so she's getting in a house she has kids
she gets to do what she wants she gets
to drive the car she wants she gets to
go on holidays and she doesn't ever know
like she doesn't she see like she
doesn't see it happen no would you be
okay with it if would you be okay if it
was vice versa
men and women are different yeah they're
different
no of course i wouldn't right i'm just
saying men and women are different 30ks
you wouldn't don't put it
yeah would you do it
right
now wait
yeah okay
40k
no there's no i can't no i wouldn't
because because because that's what i'm
saying like am i not satisfying my guy
like no you want to go to escort no
because men men are programmed to want
to spread their seed
they have a biological predisposition
yeah to want to do that and they can
make the choice in order to be with you
to not
but there's a certain percentage of guys
that have women so readily available
that they don't have to compromise
anything because there are girls that
will say you know what
i i can give up the monogamy because
this man is fine he is tall he he gives
me great sex and and i get 30k a month
why on earth like do i care if he sleeps
with a hoe every now and then